anger outside police headquarters in
london
a day after a vigil ended in scenes that
shocked many people here in the uk
demonstrators gathered mixing demands
for an end to male violence against
women
with claims that the police are part of
the problem at saturday's vigil the
focus was clearly
on women victims of male violence
here the focus has shifted with
denunciation of police brutality
hundreds had come to this south london
vigil near where sarah everard went
missing
initially police kept their distance but
their decision to move in on the crowds
and their use of force to arrest women
created outrage
home secretary pretty patel asked the
metropolitan police force for a full
report
the department said there were
unanswered questions after she met the
met chief cressida dick
and london's mayor sadiq khan from the
opposition labour party
says he's unsatisfied with her account
insisting the met
didn't honor its assurances the vigil
would be policed sensitively
but despite calls from some for cressida
dick to resign she's standing firm and
strongly defending what happened
we had a really big crowd that gathered
lots of speeches and
quite rightly as far as i can see my
team
felt this is now an unlawful gathering
which poses a considerable risk to
people's health
according to the regulations a really
invidious position for my officers to
find themselves in
labor is now set to vote against a new
policing bill in the coming days
this week in parliament we start a
policing bill
300 or so pages 170 something clauses
and almost nothing
almost nothing if you can believe it on
violence against women and girls
the gaping hole in this bill is why
we'll be voting against it
and a complete missed opportunity by the
government civil rights groups have also
criticized the legislation saying it
gives police too many powers to ban
demonstrations if they'll cause
disruption
more protests are planned near
parliament on monday as the pressure on
the capitals police force
and the politicians it answers to
increases
nadine barbara al jazeera london